none of the countries which signed on to
the Abraham Accords and most
significantly of course United Arab
Emirates have pulled out as a result of
the events of the last 11 days and I
don't expect that that will happen uh in
a certain sense the events of the last
days don't in any way push against the
dynamic of the abrahamic cours because
in many ways the abrahamic cours were
specifically a notion of bringing
together countries opposed jointly
opposed to precisely the kind of
politics and the kind of military if I
can put it that way represented since
October 7th that's to say United Arab
Emirates famously is most primarily
worried about the Muslim Brotherhood and
about Sunni islamism across the region
Kamas is a manifestation of precisely
that style of politics so October 7th
and what's happened since doesn't in any
way negate the logic of the abrahamic in
many ways on the contrary it precisely
strengthens at least the security and
defense element of the Abraham ACC